with test master set to step into the
upcoming Black Widow movie it's time to
dive into a long history that's strange
even by the standards of the Marvel
Universe
from a school for supervillains to the
South American village populated by
Hitler clones here's the truth behind
the taskmaster the taskmaster made his
first appearance in 1980s Avengers
number 195 arriving on the last page to
set up his full appearance in the next
issue man kick off a long career of
supervillain exploits created by david
michelinie and Jorge Perez he has a
superpower usually referred to as
photographic reflexes that's a fancy way
of saying that if he sees someone doing
something he can replicate that action
exactly Andy keeps that skill for the
rest of his life that would be a pretty
impressive ability in the real world but
this is a dude who lives in the Marvel
Universe he can settle in with some
footage of spider-man or black panther
and hop off the couch a few hours later
with the ability to perfectly replicate
their movements of course there's a
limit to all this photographic reflexes
are taskmasters only power that means
that while he can watch Captain America
throwing his shield and replicate the
movement it doesn't have caps
super-strength behind it still he's come
away from his many battles against the
Avengers with some pretty impressive
abilities while he's done his share of
hands-on villainy the task masters Tru
Calling has always been in education of
course his school the taskmaster Academy
is less of a learning institution and
more of a for-profit training center for
henchmen for a low price
taskmaster teaches classes of aspiring
supervillains not only how to fight like
superheroes but more importantly how to
fight against them while this mostly
functions as a pretty fantastic
explanation for where all the masked
members of Hydra and aim get the
confidence to try to punch out Iron Man
it's worth noting that it's not just the
bad guys who've taken advantage of the
taskmaster skills
he's also been responsible for training
a few of the good guys as well as the
supervillain mercenary the taskmaster
doesn't have a whole lot of friends but
one of his more enduring acquaintances
came in the form of another mercenary
Deadpool the two characters had a rocky
start to their relationship first
meeting when taskmaster attempted to use
Deadpool as a training dummy for his
students only to be foiled when Deadpool
threw him off by breaking into a
dance-off during their fight it turns
out he can only counter your moves if he
can predict them and as you may already
know Deadpool can be
unpredictable after that one of the
taskmasters most predominant roles in
the comics came when he was a member of
Deadpool supporting cast and in more
recent years the two mercenaries have
had a more back-and-forth frenemy
relationship they've occasionally come
to blows while on opposite sides of a
conflict but Deadpool was always willing
to help taskmaster out by going easy on
him in a fight
so the skull-faced opportunists could
still get paid here's where it gets a
little weird
while he's mostly shown up as a villain
or a supporting character the taskmaster
has dabbled in being a protagonist in
his own right thanks to two self-titled
miniseries the first is a relatively
straightforward action-adventure but
that second story is full on bananas the
main premise is that the taskmaster
ironically enough has a memory problem
his brain is so loaded up with shank
cheese punches and Daredevils backflips
that his muscle memory has overwritten
other plus important things like his
past to solve that he tries to track
down his own memories that leads him
through things like an encounter with
the Dawn of the Dead a Latin American
drug dealer who turns out to be a white
American SHIELD agent who taken the dawn
of the dead identity after taskmaster
trained him that however pales in
comparison to where that series ends up
be Bell's burg to a small town in the
South American Andes where Nazi
scientists escaped after World War 2 to
attempt to clone Hitler the most
successful result was the longtime
Marvel villain the hate monger who first
showed up back in 1963 but the
scientists wound up with a gigantic
stockpile of cloned Hitler brains which
leaked the bureau's biochemical essence
into the local water supply the result
every man woman and child in the town
essentially has Hitler's brain leading
to a constant warfare among themselves
for control of the area so you know the
next time someone tries to tell you how
serious the punisher is or whatever
remind them that he lives in the same
world as Hitler town beyond V bells burg
- in the dawn of the dead.the big
reveals of the taskmaster series are the
title character's origin and real name
for years the taskmaster has been
getting his orders from a secret
organization called the org but as it
turns out the org doesn't actually exist
instead it's the wife that taskmaster
doesn't remember having Mercedes Merced
who was also his partner back when he
was a SHIELD agent named wait for it
Tony masters as Nick Fury tells Steve
Rogers the taskmaster has been a good
all along he just doesn't remember it as
masters he was sent to infiltrate the
supervillain community for shield taking
the taskmaster identity as his cover
unfortunately thanks to a flawed
prototype of the Super Soldier Serum
that expanded his powers all of those
skills he'd absorbed over wrote the
personal parts of his memory
Mercedes has been minimizing the damage
for years by acting as taskmasters
handler and pointing him in the right
directions of course once he discovers
all this his brain immediately erases it
in favor of another new fighting style
putting a heartbroken Mercedes right
back into the role of working with a
husband who doesn't remember she exists
while it's doubtful that say that Dawn
of the Dead will show up it's not
difficult to imagine how taskmaster
might fit into the Black Widow movie
most of Natasha Romanovs history has to
do with her training in the Red Room a
secret Soviet program designed to create
a series of highly trained agents who
were given the codename of Black Widow
with the taskmasters history and his
ability to serve as the perfect teacher
in virtually any style of combat it's
easy to picture him as one of Natasha's
trainers and maybe even the person who's
sent to clean things up once she defects
the shield sure that's a pretty
straightforward espionage plot but it's
also one that could fit neatly into the
world of the MCU then again given that
we've seen Infinity stones the
Celestials and a talking raccoon in
those movies there's always a chance
that taskmaster and Widow will end up
fighting a climactic battle in Beebe
ellsberg to seeing Marvel characters
beating up a couple hundred Hitler's
might just make Black Widow the
feel-good movie of the year check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]